[Musique]
voir les enfants pas trop excusez bois
apprenait les nicolas m'attendent je
suis un peu précieux mais vas-y nounours
j'ai appris mon échelle
alors pour le père
mais oui nicolas tu as deux oreilles il
ya deux semaines et maintenant elles
sont propres et toi tu apprenais tu as
donné aux ma pauvre petit pas preneur
dieudonné
[Musique]
écolo s'est pas coupé alors nous allons
voir ça tous au tableau noir moi je sais
très bien compter venez je vais vous
montrer un chicana
des côtes jusqu'à dix noms mais oui on
va voir pas preneur combien y at-il de
pommes sur la table
toi et quatre non 4 et 6 non après 4 il
ya cinq bon ton la une
3 4 u 5 bravo et combien y at-il de cube
[Musique]
mais oui c'est ça bras font donc il ya
cinq cubes et sacs pomme 5 + 5 ça fait
10 oui saclay safadi voyons le tableau
ans
il ya 5
vendu 6 en or 3
combien ça fait rire tout
5 + 3
ça fait neuf non
sa fin
oui 8 j'ajoute encore une preuve ça fait
9 exactement
allons nous recompte ont tous ensemble a
[Musique]
dit ranger vous comptez jusqu'à d'esprit
mais côté jyske m
je vous félicite
bravo
odudu
10 c'est amusant de savoir compter dit
tu nous ferons encore compte nous nous
ce premier petit la 1 2 3 géant
l'allumeur quatre cinq six années 90 7 8
9 et beauvais u10
adoma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
savez-vous compter jusqu'à 10 les
enfants
si vous ne savez pas essayez vous verrez
c'est très amusant
deux ou trois au patron mais oui en
route mon gros nounours bonne nuit des
enfants allez vite vous coucher et fait
tout pour 1
[Musique]
oh